the other Celebrity Death I'm going to
mention right now Suzanne Summers sexy
Suzanne Summers oh my God what hard this
morning yeah she was on a a bunch of our
shows back in the day when nobody came
on and um she would come on with her
husband Allan and they had a great
marriage and uh it reminds me of you in
a marriage because she says for 42 years
they have never been aart I love
together
she had it she was the beautiful woman
in the white Thunderbird and American
Graffiti but then she hit it big as
Chrissy snow in thre's company on ABC
one of the things too that she did when
wisely she built up her career around th
Master you remember Thigh Master that
was amazing she swore by that Thigh
Master if you remember the commercial
great legs thank you how do you get them
I used to do aerobics till I dropped
then I found th master every single time
you squeeze Thigh Master you strengthen
and tone right where you need it so it's
easy to squeeze squeeze your way to
shapely hips and thighs I didn't buy it
honestly yeah but every woman
did they did she made a lot of money
with it and like I said she appeared on
my show multiple times in the 80s and
90s with her husband too he was always
with her he was always with her and like
I kind of liked her alone you know what
I mean would have been a better fantasy
I really liked her she was very mind to
us and to our show and she influenced a
lot of people over the course of her
life and her you know Health regimes uh
let's go to Lisa Robin in Massachusetts
who wants to say good morning good
morning Lisa good morning Howard I just
wanted to let you know that Suzanne was
so incredibly important to my career I
was working or volunteering I should say
at a community radio station I created a
health show she came on and after she
came on she was so happy with it that
she told her publicist and all of a
sudden I'm getting all these requests
from different celebrities and
publicists and I ended up being able to
Syndicate my show to eight stations
including two NPR stations and every
time Suzanne came on she was so gracious
and kind and always said my name a lot
Lisa this was great Lisa thank you and
she was just so kind and we stayed in
touch and it I was crying last night it
just broke my heart so she's really
she's so special she sure
was